[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au sommaire de ce 25 mars la mère de
plaisir menacé des gestes d'intimidation
ont été proférées à l'encontre de
joséphine coleman ce berger les faits se
sont produits mercredi lors du dernier
conseil municipal
à l'ordre du jour une délibération sur
la transformation du vally bout en
écoquartier l'élu a porté plainte
interview dans cette édition l'événement
fête ses 20 ans le raid amazones est un
rendez-vous 100% féminin accessible à
tous les niveaux sportif pour cet
anniversaire de cours sont organisés au
sri lanka avec deux yvelinoise en lice
et dominique bouchet habitants de
morcourt a terminé 18e de la première
course maria renoue de triel-sur-seine
prendra le départ de la deuxième ce
dimanche
et puis nos idées de sorties pour le
week-end avec notamment le printemps de
la sculpture de la course à pied une
grande journée au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
on a eu un conseil municipal qui était
un conseil municipal je dirais classique
avec bien sûr plusieurs points à l'ordre
du jour dont dont le renouvellement et
je dirais et l'acceptation du projet en
rue sur les animaux qui était ni plus ni
moins que l'acceptation des 64 millions
d'euros qui sont qui vont être injectés
dans le quartier pour des projets m'a vu
débarquer
pas mal de personnes très très très
violemment expressive qui tapait très
fortement sur les portes sur les
fenêtres du conseil municipal puisque on
mettait en vision moi j'étais seul avec
des personnes de l'administration
générale qui d'ailleurs était très
apeuré
j'ai porté plainte parce que je
considère qu'en tant que représentant
des habitants en tant que élus de la
république je ne peux pas accepter qu'on
me fasse quand mon encontre parce que je
veux dire c'est geste n'était pas fait
de façon large c'était vraiment me
regardant bien dans les yeux c'est
quelque chose que je ne peux pas
accepter donc les suites je n'en sais
rien
qui était clair un jeudi qu'il était
hors de question de laisser intimider
par ce genre de choses il était hors de
question d'arrêter ce projet de toute
façon si on devait arrêter ce projet
bien nous perdrons les 64 millions
d'euros aujourd'hui on va comme je
lisais commencer les vraiment les
négociations et des discussions avec
tout le monde pour parler surtout de
cette fameuse salle associative qui va
être ouverte aux gens du quartier qui en
ont véritablement besoin
[Musique]
le conseil municipal de triel sur seine
a été également perturbé mercredi par
une douzaine d'individus à la sortie de
la séance houleuse un homme de 32 ans a
agressé un policier municipal il a reçu
plusieurs coups de pieds à la tête et au
plexus
les agents ont dû faire usage de leur
armement collectif le policier n'a pas
été hospitalisé mais il a porté plainte
l'individu interpellé pour violences
volontaires en réunion contre une
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique le maire cédric aoun évoque une
instrumentalisation de son opposition
qui s'en défend et dénonce de son côté
un dénigrement de l'édile la présence
récemment renforcée sur le terrain de la
police municipale serait à l'origine de
ces tensions
[Musique]
un
hommage à jonathan arrivé et gabriel
sandler et merial monsonego le 19 mars
2012 il perdait la vie à toulouse devant
l'école juive ozar hatorah dans un
attentat terroriste
la ville de versailles est la préfecture
ont rappelé leurs souvenirs le père et
grand-père de trois des victimes et
président honoraire de l'association
cultuelle israélite de versailles sacha
assure une conversation sur la santé
sexuelle une application avec
intelligence artificielle
elle a été lancée ce 22 mars par
l'association hf prévention faire tomber
les barrières entre valides et personnes
à mobilité réduite
la société omni développe des
trottinettes électriques adaptés à tous
un projet soutenu par saint quentin en
yvelines elles protestent contre les
multiples projets urbains privé dans le
département des yvelines neuf
associations de protection de
l'environnement ont choisi de s'allier
de saisir la justice
plus de 150 jeunes se sont affrontés
avec un objectif en tête gagner une
place pour les championnats de france
pionnière accueillir les championnats
scolaires académique d'échec la reprise
économique est bien réel salon et qui
n'avait été de nouveau organiser une
quinzaine de sociétés saint-quentinoise
a répondu présentes
[Musique]
holy notre vie normalement les gens vont
travailler les gens gros s'est terminée
avec les enfants
les enfants des écoles
où il y à des écoles dans ma vie là on a
les écoles ont vite tout à fait
normalement mais en même temps on fait
avec avec la guerre donc on faire coli o
nos
soldats réfugié en a beaucoup plus que
200 mille îles ça arrive brute ses puces
[Musique]
mais après vous avez les villes où les
gens sont lequel pour pas quitter pour
le sommet
butch il ne pouvait pas quitter si
facilement
les gens 125 les on n'a pas de connexion
n'a pas de réseau vous avez pas de gaz
vous n'avez pas de l'homme savait rien
du tout il y à déjà les viols les vols
dit pas mais il a déjà les viols qui qui
sont commis et qui vont nous être en
vente mon patio
5 est un peu bientôt
plus tôt on attend
on attend
une menace on vous avait déjà plus à
plaindre vous attendez seulement vous
faites avec
les gens qui sont nés ici encore percé
ou en fait avec ça tout et tout ce qui
vous adressez aux
esprits comme ce qui trait combattants
patriotisme vous le sentez partout et à
salon bi de gagner y plus vite possible
[Musique]
selon l'équipe de campagne d'emmanuel
macron une loi de programmation
pluriannuelle préserverait
l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel public
le contexte rappelons le c'est celui
d'une promesse de suppression de la
redevance en tant que taxe affectée à
l'audiovisuel public ce qui a cours dans
le inspire bien des craintes or pas plus
que la redevance une loi de
programmation essentiellement symbolique
ne garantirait l'indépendance de ce
service public les lois de finances
pluriannuelle ou dite loi de
programmation ne garantissent aucunement
le maintien d'un budget en réalité elle
se borne à prévoir des budgets sur
plusieurs années mais juridiquement elle
n'ouvre eu aucun crédit c'est à dire
qu'elles ne permettent aucune dépense
ainsi une loi de programmation pourrait
très solennellement prévoir que
l'audiovisuel sera pourvu de 6 milliards
d'euros chaque année sur trois ans et
pourtant aucun euro ne pourraient être
dépensés il faut pour cela qu'une la loi
de finances annuelles la seule à
permettre les dépenses ouvre des crédits
chaque année
or l'expérience des lois de
programmation n'est pas glorieuse il est
assez fréquent que la majorité
parlementaire oublie le programme
qu'elle a voté auparavant il loi de
programmation dans les faits sont
rarement respectées jusqu'à leur terme
alors que faire il serait possible
d'inscrire l'existence de l'audiovisuel
public dans la constitution à l'instar
par exemple de l'enseignement et pour
sanctuariser son budget une autorité
indépendante serait probablement la
mieux placée toutefois les dépenses
publiques font partie des prérogatives
du parlement en tant que représentant du
peuple ceci est un héritage de la
révolution française et de la
déclaration de 1789 et donc à travers le
parlement c'est le citoyen qui consent à
une dépense publique et pour cette
raison il n'est pas possible pour le
parlement de se défaire de son pouvoir
financier
alors pour le dire autrement
l'audiovisuel public n'est pas en tout
cas pour le moment au dessus des lois ce
que le parlement lui accorde il peut lui
retirer c'est lui qui décide de son
budget libre ensuite à tous les groupes
de pression de jouer le rôle que
finalement c'est aussi la démocratie
[Musique]
elle
ici elle
elles sont 450 baroudeuse à se donner
rendez vous au sri-lanka répartis en
équipes de deux ou de trois les amazones
se défieront pendant six jours vtt canoë
trail tir à l'arc 2 yvelinoise ont
décidé de se lancer dans cette aventure
là le raid amazones au sri lanka c'est
ça va être absolument génial de pouvoir
aller à la rencontre des gens de visiter
un pays de s'intégrer dans la culture
dominique elle participe avec ses deux
filles virginie 44 ans et aurélie 40 ans
elle représente l'équipe des wonder
serait elle-même la de reprendre la
compétition toutes les trois c'est un
vrai plaisir même si je sais que ça va
être dur mais en des hauts et des bas ça
va être très dur mais bon voilà on verra
la découverte le raid amazones c'est
aussi l'occasion de se dépasser
physiquement pour une cause c'est
l'occasion d'en parler à travers nos
réseaux sociaux et puis d'essayer dé
soutenir un peu plus que d'habitude
financièrement justement avec aussi ce
qu'on pourra avoir de nos partenaires
mon petit fils est atteint d'un syndrome
un syndrome épileptique syndrome de drap
s est une maladie rare 350 cas en france
donc ça entraîne des des retards
psychomoteurs
il mort subite voilà tahoua 14 ans et
donc on représente l'association de tao
et c'est notre comment je vais dire
notre point d'ancrage setao voilà dès
qu'il ya un petit problème tao voilà
notre entraînement tout ça c'est à eau
une aventure sportive solidaire et
humaine il ya aussi des amitiés thinès
et à travers ses amitiés on apprend tout
à se connaître et pendant les épreuves
c'est super quel que soit le niveau on
s'encourage tout même la dernière où
l'attend on lui fait la ola et surtout
on est impressionné par les dernières
même des fois parce que elles ont moins
de temps de repos entre deux épreuves
que nous forcément et il ya aussi des
raids ou les femmes viennent pour se
dépasser même si elles sont malades même
si elles suivent des traitements et ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on qu'on partage
énormément pour célébrer les 20 ans du
raid amazones deux courses ont été
organisées dominique est déjà revenu
avec ses deux filles elles ont terminé
18e sur 28 de son côté marie sera dans
l'avion pour le sri lanka dimanche 27
mars
[Musique]
une opération gratuite qui met en valeur
en fait le patrimoine culture le
patrimoine sculpture pardon on a des
animations qui vont s'organiser autour
de 22 sites partenaires donc il y en a
dix sept qui sont dans les
hauts-de-seine il y en a quatre dans le
78 on a le musée de la fondation
coubertin saint rémy les chevreuse le
musée de saint quentin en yvelines la
commanderie à elancourt et le musée
d'archéologie nationale à saint germain
en laye
[Musique]
c'est un travail de maillage en fait
territoriales pour que d'abord on aille
au devant de tous les publics sur ce
week end du 25 au 27 mars qu'on puisse
et bien visiter et avoir un parcours
intéressant autour des oeuvres sculptées
il va y avoir une chasse aux sculptures
par exemple qui va être organisée
également et qui va qui va sûrement
beaucoup intéressé les familles
il ya une programmation en ligne et ça
ça va permettre effectivement aux
habitants de nos deux départements de
pouvoir découvrir plus de cent
sculptures
autour de d'un certain nombre de
thématiques alors les animaux dans la
sculpture par exemple pour comprendre
que le plus facile sur le site du
printemps de la sculpture on aura
rendez-vous dans des musées de façon
virtuelle pour découvrir ou des
fondations ou des parcs sans bouger de
chez soi et bien on aura accès on aura
accès à ces sculptures et à ses oeuvres
qui sont disséminés dans sur le
territoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour terminer cette émission les
traditionnel agenda à suivre dans les
yvelines sculptrice française d'origine
hongroise martha panne est à l'origine
de l'une des oeuvres les plus connues de
saint quentin en yvelines après avoir
travaillé avec de grands noms comme
brancusi ou le corbusier elle s'établit
dans les yvelines à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse avec son mari
andré wogenscky une partie de ses
oeuvres se trouvant au japon elle a
également agrémenté certains lieux
français de sa touche abstraite parmi
eux les étangs l'escalier les arcs et le
pont place incontournable de saint
quentin en yvelines c'est la perspective
de martha panne à guyancourt qui sera
prochainement restaurer ce vendredi 25
mars à 19 heures un spectacle
chorégraphique sera présenté par la
compagnie retouramont l'occasion de
célébrer cette restauration du sport et
du spectacle ce samedi 26 mars le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines accueille ses premiers bmx pro
series entre courses chaud et animations
les meilleurs riders du monde seront
réunis pour s'affronter dans un format
coupe du monde un tour de qualification
pour les phases finales pour des
sportifs de 5 à 99 ans et le soir le
retour d'un rendez vous des plus
insolites la beauté de ce parti à partir
de 22h30 des courses de petites motos en
relais et des choses inédit bonne
ambiance garantie jusqu'au bout de la
nuit un petit repas pour une grande
cause l'équipe compagnon de scouts et
guides de france organise un dîner
caritatif le samedi 2 avril prochain à
guyancourt concert magie et spectacles
de danse rythmeront la soirée dans
l'objectif de récolter un maximum de
dons l'argent sera utilisé pour partir
l'été prochain en slovénie effectué de
l'éducation et de l'animation auprès de
jeunes slovènes marginalisés pour les
réservations ou toute demande
d'information contacter l'organisateur
au 07 81 67 62 05 enfin les visionnaires
premier salon du livre de saint quentin
en yvelines le 1er et 2 avril prochains
rendez vous au vélodrome nationale en
présence de l'auteur et cyclistes
professionnels guillaume martin
président du jury très bon week end sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]